so listening is not the act of hearing
the words spoken it is the art of
understanding the meaning behind those
words
and
you know when people say you're not
listening to me and we simply parrot
back the words that they were said
congratulations your ears work you know
that is the act that is the act of
listening
um
but the art of listening is is creating
an environment in which the other person
feels heard now you notice what i said
there the other person and i used an
emotional word feels right i don't want
to know that you heard the words i want
to feel
i want to feel heard i feel seen i want
to feel understood and that is a
learnable practical learnable
practicable skill
so it's uh there are many parts of it
it's things like replacing judgment with
curiosity
right that's a hard thing to do we're a
pretty judgy group
right to be curious why someone has a
point of view it's creating a safe space
for someone to as my as my friend dia
khan calls it empty the bucket so even
if we find what they're saying just
reprehensible
right you're never going to be able to
actually have dialogue until
at least one of the parties
gets the opportunity to say everything
without judgment
and as she calls it emptying the bucket
and once a person somebody feels like
they've completely said everything
then they're more apt to listen to you
but usually what we do is we defend
or we litigate or we interrupt we point
out flaws in logic which is just
frustrating and when you point out some
flaws in somebody's logic because we're
all imperfect when we speak and we all
choose the wrong words at various times
and that's not what i meant you know
what i meant is what we have to say well
what if you know what you meant why
don't you say what you you can see how
this spirals um
uh um but it's things like when somebody
says something you know and there's
really easy ways to do it things like go
on
tell me more
what else
and they keep talking
and you go quiet they feel the space
tell me more
go on
and eventually
it's all out
and then there's a safe space for you to
respond or to and express yourself in a
constructive way but but that's correct
we we
we do not teach listening and listening
is the way
to create um
to build trust with someone
you know you make someone feel heard
they'll trust you you know
it is the way to find common ground
in opposition
in simple cases in business but in more
complicated cases uh in national
politics or in global politics or in war
you know
why do you know we
my bill yuri william yuri who wrote
getting to yes
he talks about the same thing he goes we
have talk shows but we don't have listen
shows he says we have peace talks but
what we really need is peace listens you
know and and he who's been at the table
of
the highest levels of peace negotiations
he said people show up and start
demanding what they want and that's how
the negotiations begin nobody starts by
saying so tell me why you came here
there's a great documentary that i
recommend
to learn this it's called white right
meeting the enemy by dia khan
in a nutshell dia is a muslim woman
living in the uk who was trolled by
white supremacists to the point where
the police got involved because her life
was at risk they told her stay away from
open windows that's how bad it got
the way dia responded was by moving to
the united states and going to meet the
white supremacists
and she brought her cameras i mean you
can see it all happen in this
documentary and basically she gave them
a safe space
to feel heard now that sounds mad like
why should she give them a safe space to
feel her they should give her a safe
space yeah fine good you know like it's
never going to happen
dear sits down with these white
supremacists and she gives them a safe
space to feel heard it's extreme
listening
um and i say it's extreme because i mean
they hate her you know they don't just
disagree with her
uh they want her off the planet
um and uh
and she lets them empty their bucket as
she calls it
and then conversation begins
and because they feel heard
they start to trust her
and as i start to trust her she becomes
a friend
and then what it creates
this paradox where i'm supposed to hate
this woman but i trust her and consider
a friend and what you see is one by one
these white supremacists these die-hard
white supremacists start dropping out of
the movement because they can no longer
reconcile their beliefs with reality
and if
if it can happen in this extreme
environment
then it can happen anywhere
and um all that is required for us to
cross political divides or
you know
disagreements at work and things like
that is one of the parties
has to learn how to listen it doesn't
even require both parties to learn the
skill that's the amazing thing
and uh it is it is one of the most
remarkable remarkable skills that anyone
can learn the power of listening yeah so
the documentary is a great extreme
example of
what it can do